We have a subreddit for the David Pakman show,
which is one of the larger sort of single
show subreddits, uh, for progressive media.
We have over 16,000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed@davidpakman.com slash Reddit one
this, there's actually more than one example,
but I picked one. There are a lot of posts
showing up on our subreddit about people concerned
at Bernie's dropping poll numbers.
Here's one example from a user named some
jerk 27 who says, Bernie Sanders has been
dropping in the polls. There's been a lot
of talk about Buddha judge rising and Warren
going down, but I haven't heard as much about
what's happening to Bernie. Bernie picked
up some speed in the last two months getting
up to 19% on average, but in the last couple
of weeks he's fallen down again to only 15%
he's still technically in second place, but
that's only because Warren continues falling.
This is worrying for me as a Bernie supporter.
We've got to find a way to get him back up
again. Stop Buddha judge defect, a defeat
Joe Biden, although I don't like as much as
Bernie Warren's fall is also worrying, so
there are a lot of people sharing this concern.
I'm actually going to be doing a commentary.
We'll, I will explain how the establishment
getting behind Pete Buddha judge actually
helps Joe Biden even though the instinct might
be that it divides the establishment vote
between Biden and Buddha judge.
And this is playing into the dynamics of what's
going on with Bernie and Warren. All I can
say to you is while I don't believe that the
polls are inaccurate, it is still early enough
that anyone who's in the running can still
win. There are four key primaries, Iowa, New
Hampshire, Nevada and South Carolina that
will actually set the tone. Of course, the
polling gives us a sense of how those are
going to go. But focus in if you want to see
Bernie, uh, carry this through to the nomination,
focus in on getting involved in those four
States, particularly Iowa and New Hampshire
since those were the first two. I don't think
anything is a foregone conclusion. I get emails
from people who delusional. He say Bernie
is definitely going to be the nominee. Well
that's not clear. But I also get emails from
people who say Bernie has done and that's
definitely not the case at this point.
P booted judges rise is evidence of that.
He looked like he was out a few months ago.
He's now right in there actually polling,
um, uh, as high as Bernie and Warren in some
polls in some polls, although he's still in
fourth place on average. So my advice to you
is if you don't like what's going on, get
active. We know the strategy. There's four
States, four key States that you can get involved
in and it is still early enough for Bernie
Sanders to do very well, but he might not
as well. And I think that only being tied
to reality is the best path forward. He's
not obviously going to win. He's not obviously
going to lose. It's going to come down to
what happens in the next few months. Another
post I saw what's happening to David asks,
Rickard 58, I'm a long time listener of the
show. David's recent takes on Latin America
and his concern trolling on Medicare for all.
Have me wondering if he's moving more to the
center or if he's trying to appeal more to
the intellectual dark web called this crowd
in some of his videos. What are your thoughts?
Well, two things on this. Number one, uh,
from a qualitative standpoint, my views on
these issues, none of my views on these issues
have changed. I've always been for Medicare
for all, but understood the practical difficulty
of making it a reality. And I'm still for
Medicare for all. There's been no change.
Uh, my views on Latin American politics have
been the same for, you know, I don't know,
years and years and years. Uh, it may be that
my audience is changing around me. It may
be that my audience isn't changing and I'm
not changing, but that there are more other
ideas that are getting traction in media and
thus creating a contrast with me.
That's certainly a possibility. As far as
moving to the center, we recently, I've done,
I've had the pleasure of publicly doing, um,
those political spectrum quizzes. There's
so many different ones. There's the eight
values, one political compass. There's a one
called pup police scales or something like
that. I've done all of these over the years
and I've actually moved to the left on every
single one of those tests. I'm more to the
left today than I ever was, so that's, I guess
all I have to say about it. Uh, join the discussion@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit. That's R. E. D. D. I. T.